All right, so we have a problem.
The brightest constraint equation
gives us more unknowns than equations.
More directions to move
than we have pixels.
How are we going to recover the motion?
Obviously, we need
some extra constraints.
We need some additional constraints.
So, we'll talk about sort of
a global approach now, and
the next time we'll talk about
a more local approach that,
that's actually used and, in fact,
some of you may even implement.
Some time long, long ago in
a galaxy nearby Berthold Horn and
Brad Schunk did some work on what
was called smooth optical flows.
And basically they said,
let's try to come up with an optical
flow that minimizes some error.
Okay?
So the first part of the error is
how much do we violate the optic,
the brightness constancy
constraint equation, right?
Basically, that middle term right there,
that's supposed to be zero.
Right?
Ixu plus Iyv plus I sub t is equal
to zero.
So, violations of that
means that it's not zero.
Sometimes it's positive
sometimes negative.
I square it, and
I sum it up over the whole image.
That would be how bad my flow is with
respect to the constraint equation.
All right?
But we know we can solve that exactly
because we have more unknowns
than constraints, so If that's our only
constraint, we're, we're not done.
But we're going to call
this the constraint error.
By the way, I kept partially originally
I'd stolen, then I did on my own, I kept
the integral signs instead of summations
because back when this work was done
we'd like to think about images as
actually continual, continual functions.
Of course,
if you were to implement this,
you'd actually have to do summations.
I'll also tell you the fact that
summations are not integrals matters and
if you take a look at some of the work
that was done in shape from shading,
doing it as an integral
was actually hard.
Doing it in summations was,
in some sense, a little bit easier.
But for here,
the difference doesn't matter, so
I just wrote it as being
summed up over the image.
So here we have our optic
flow constraint term.
Now we need another term.
Well, it says smooth optical flow,
here's the idea.
Remember when we did stereo?
The, the state of the art
solution that I showed you
with that beautiful recovery?
Used a bunch of terms,
some that had to do with the data, but
it also had to do with the smoothness
of the disparity field?
That was the idea that surfaces don't
change a lot, all over the place.
But they tend to have a particular
depth or very smoothly.
The same could be said of motion,
that is, so if I've got something moving
around, the motion vectors from one
point to the next change slowly.
So let me come up with a penalty
term that says I really don't like
velocity fields where the velocity
changes quickly from one
location to the neighboring location.
So that's shown here.
These ux, ui,
that's the derivative of u.
Remember, u is the x component
of the motion field.
The derivative in the x direction
squared, because it'd be positive,
negative, derivative in the y
direction squared, same thing as here,
which is v sub x, v sub y,
the change of v as you move in x,
the change in v as you move in y.
Again, everything is squared.
So the idea is, we would like
this thing to be, like, zero, or
as little as possible.
By the way, what would it mean for
this to be zero?
Well, for this to be zero,
that would mean that all
the u's were constant, right?
They were all the same value, so
the derivatives would be zero.
And all the v's would be constant.
So if all my pixels were
moving with the same uv,
the whole image was moving the same
direction, this value would be zero.
Any other u's and v's will cause
this term to have some value,
and we want to try to
minimize this thing.
So now, we have these two terms.
We have the constraint
equation error term and
we have the smoothness error term called
e sub c, e sub s and what we want to do
is we want to find the uv at every pixel
and there's going to be a different
uv at every pixel that minimizes
this total error which is just
the smoothness term plus some waiting
factor times the constraint term.
And the waiting factor is sort of,
how much you believe your data.
So, the bigger the waiting factor is
the more important the satisfying
the brightness constancy constraint is,
the smaller the waiting factor, the more
the smoothness term dominates and what
value it should have is a function of
sort of how much noise there is and how
smooth you believe the entire thing is.
So, this was part of a, a general
approach, variational approach where
you're going to solve for uv as a
function of xy that is, you're going to
find the optic flow u and v for every
pixel that tries to minimize this error.
It's somewhat painful to try
to implement systems that can
solve for that.
Not impossible.
But the idea is that you have a global
constraint, the smoothness constraint,
to help solve your problem.